but the election's gonna be fun folks
get ready for the election it's
it's gonna be a fun one and i i do
think
democracy has not worked can we say that
can we put that out there as a thesis
can we throw that out as a thesis and
then work backwards from there
yes or yes i'm i'm asking you do you
look around and feel that democracy has
really
worked maybe it hasn't even been tried i
mean we're a republic we're not a
democracy
but uh we're not even that we're more
like an oligarchy and then that's also
failing right the oligarchy is kind of
failing because
you know dave smith made a good point
about this
i'm not a libertarian but i do like dave
a lot um
people we we all know the people are
nuts
you know the people a lot of the blm
antifa types that are like knocking over
restaurants
are nuts we know that we see them we go
that's a crazy person
we see we we say that's a crazy person
because we know
there's no root from what they're doing
to anything
better right we know that by knocking
over brunch tables we're not gonna we're
not getting to an equitable fair
uh society where people are treated with
respect and it's also the wrong goal by
the way
the goal should be to change laws and to
have laws
uh govern people's lives so that they
have uh the maximum amount of
opportunity the goal should not be
um to uh create or change
everything at once because none of that
ever happens or ever works
um each we should there should be
specific pinpoint
focus on things that are [ __ ] people
and that you can change and and that it
you it shouldn't just be this broad eat
the rich horseshit that never works
never has worked
um and and the other side of it the rich
is just
some type of authoritarian uh socialist
uh state that is run by people
that will uh corrupt like every leader
does and then run the state into the
ground and run everybody
uh that lives there into the ground as
well um that's just historically what
has happened right there's no
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
like the carried interest loophole on
wall street you should eliminate
that should be a [ __ ] get rid of that
first
does it mean you don't do anything else
but it means like there's things you can
actually [ __ ] do
or try to do um but we know that the
people knocking over
the brunch tables are nuts and we know
on the other side the people that are
walking around talking about an ethno
state
uh you know with ar-15s you don't really
want to throw your hat in with those
people either that's just not what you
you look at both groups of people you go
i bet they're not going to run a real
great society if we give them the
opportunity
right 17 year old gamers who want to
bring back the monarchy
versus fat non-binary women from seattle
both
options negan for society
but we forget and this is dave smith's
point how radical the center is
how crazy the center is
how truly detached the elites are the
center
they have also left the planet
the center and i don't mean the
the majority of people in america when i
say the center i mean the people that
have any power
any influence the people that are
elected the people that are behind the
people that are elected
those people as well are completely out
of it the
centrists the ones in the middle cannot
just be
for eternal war and a financial system
that crushes people
and and and no health care and that's
the center
those are the safe people that's the
safe
choice just unending war
manipulating [ __ ] you know
currency crashing economies all over the
world
driving our economy off a cliff every
seven years
in his boom and bus cycle you know
charging off all of our debt letting it
be serviced by all these other countries
that's the center and that's
also a big problem i think people forget
that because it's easy to point out
how crazy the people on the streets are
but why are the people on the streets
because the center
the people in the suits the people that
look respectable
the people that have lovely families and
you go sit down with them you have lunch
with them
when they start talking you go oh you as
well are [ __ ]
insane you as well have lost it
i was in the hamptons talking to people
they're going isn't the
aren't the problems mainly on twitter
i'm like they're burning down what
their cities are falling and you people
are drinking rose in your backyard
they don't have a clue they're out of it
they're living in this insular bubble
they have no idea what is happening
and they're the center they are the
buddha judge klobuchar
centrist they're not people that you
would ever
point out and go that's a lunatic but
when you hear them talk
and when you realize that the policies
they fail they don't
think it's a problem that we have the
level of wealth inequality that we do
they don't think it's an issue um and i
and i and one of them said to me that uh
one of them said well wait a minute
they go what is this what's the problem
with this so wealth inequality
so i'll give you a few problems but i
said the the one the one major
one of the major issues that i can
because i'm i'm i'm smart enough to
realize i'm not gonna try like an
emotional appeal with these people
i said a lot of if you have a small
group of people
that have all of the money they also
have all of the political power
so the problem is that in a democratic
system or a republic or whatever we
[ __ ] are under the impression this
thing is
if you give all of them if the money is
earned
and hoarded and capped by one small
group of people they also make
all of the decisions uh syringe in your
ass bill gates you know so that becomes
an issue too
and um and they said oh i can see your
point there a little
i go yeah a little bit i see that i said
you see
said people don't have any power anymore
right as you guys
and then one of them goes well they can
vote that's what they say
you can vote just vote
what's the problem and i'm like yeah but
the lobbying and the legalized bribery
the bribery that isn't legal the
blackmail
all the uh skullduggery all the fun that
you people have been having forever
yeah that that kind of that that kind of
overrides
the vote doesn't it not saying you
shouldn't vote
um and i'm not saying by the way that
the opposite of voting is like let's go
[ __ ] up a brunch
because somehow then these people are
going to be dethroned but the centers is
is fairly radical it's
wild when you talk to people and they're
not radical in their appearance
and they're not radical in um in
in many of their beliefs like many of
them are are pretty
you know regular you know down the down
the middle kind of
but when you start talking to them we're
all radicalized by our self-interest
this is really what it comes down to i
think that's part of the issue the
radical nature
of a lot of people's beliefs um
sometimes it goes against their
self-interest
but a lot of times it is perfectly in
line with what they
want either the world to look like and
even if you don't understand
someone's self-interest like you look at
all these rich kids uh
saying that they want communism well
that doesn't make any sense it does when
you realize that they actually just want
anyone to pay attention to them and that
that's the one thing they haven't been
able to buy
is their value and worth as a human
being
so that's why they're they're walking
around unironically calling themselves
maoists walking out of starbucks with a
cold brew
and then and then stomping around the
suburbs saying that they're maoist they
just want [ __ ] attention so that is
in their self-interest
but i mean all these wall street [ __ ]
out there in the hamptons and i only
spoke to a handful of them
but the ones that i spoke to are are
incredibly detached from what is
actually happening out there they just
don't care
and and when they talk about it
their belief it is a radical belief to
say
is aren't the problems just on twitter
that's a pretty radical wild
take because they they can afford
the news many of them
are friends of the people who run those
company
you know the news right you could just
turn it on or glance at it
occasionally and you would see
how big these problems are and how
widespread they are
to say something like isn't it mainly on
twitter
shows that you're just so completely
removed from it and that's why
a lot of these elites are just incapable
of charting the right course
for america so so if trump leaves don't
think for a minute that
the people coming in i mean biden was
chosen because he is a corpse
make no mistake he was chosen because he
is a corpse
and because he's a company man and he's
going to go in there and they're going
to
keep with the same policies
and the same attitude that created
trump that type of empire at all costs
[ __ ] the people mentality
uh politics is beyonce shaking her ass
and having a trans batman that
level of commitment to the american
people
workers can [ __ ] off people that have
families can [ __ ] off
uh you know but if you want to jet
around to little st
james you'll have the best legal defense
possible
um but politics being primarily the
color of the superhero
is has not worked and that's what it is
a very aesthetic optics-based politics
in which nothing gets done by design
and little people get little uh
breadcrumbs a little nugget of this and
that
here you go enjoy this obama came in
tried
you know that didn't work